Knitting cables on the knitting
machine can be a challenge.
The crossing of the stitches can be
difficult, plus adding purl stitches
for a hand knit look can be tedious.
Now, I've always considered using
the ribber to add purl stitches,
but I'd never tried it.
Here are the results of my
experiment with this idea.
I set up my knitting with four needles
in work on the main bed and two
needles in work on the ribber.
I'm planning a two by two cable with two
purl stitches between each cable.
Remember that when we're crossing cables
on the machine, we're stretching those
stitches considerably, relying on the
stretch of the yarn to make the cross.
You may even notice that my needles
are being pulled out of position.
And this is just a simple
two by two cable.
Nothing fancy.
What I found is that no matter how I
held the transfer tools, no matter what
angle I held them, this is clumsy at best.
Plus, the stitches on the ribber are very
tight and tend to pop off and misform.
Try it yourself, but I'll
bet you have similar results.
My conclusion with this experiment is
that I'll cross cables on the single bed
and relatch purl stitches that I want.
Or, better yet, leave cables
for hand knitting projects.
What do you think?